[Music]
alright and we are live I'll or podcast
once again with that net slaw kognito
who is this fine gentleman we have in
the room today hey I was going my name
is Victor Burgos with virgos games say
name I am developing net go ghost jump
oh there goes Jeff is a 2d 3d puzzle
platformer 2 main mechanics for the game
are that you can switch between your 2d
camera and 3d camera perspectives at any
time you can also switch between your
physical form and your ghost form at any
time let's see it and you use any toes
mechanics to basically sell puzzles
comment enemies like that this first
level is all about you know trying to
get the player into the jump into
nothing nothing too crazy going on here
animation
[Music]
nice alright there we go here and then a
little laggy there but those times
alright then we got leaderboards in
every single level so for all those
competitive people that want to speed
around through the game we got something
for you okay and this is the main
mechanic here so two DS so in Italy he
can't get past this section in 2d so now
we go to 3d to switch so there you go
around outside nice size so there you go
here and here's another one I can't get
through now I go oh wait what's this
what's this and bam and then BAM is that
you jump nice love that aspect very
unique concept the meshing of the 2d
with the 3d look and I hopped out but
what's this whole thing with this anchor
that's just to signify the end of the
stage now so the story behind it is that
neck come in and that could grow up are
you getting married
look up space dog pirates you come in on
his wedding day and abduct his bride to
beat all his friends and family
yeah so the pirate ship has an anchor I
was right so basically he's trying to
get to up top to this pirate ship okay
just barely missing it at every single
time this is torture bed so it should've
been with this wet day trying to get
back to wifey so this is the second
mechanic here where we have introduced
combat
so you hit why I'm here and then BAM now
your ghost for yeah so let's get you go
back here so just because you're a ghost
worm doesn't mean anything your physical
form is still under attack oh and now
you
Wow so you have to be very careful but
this is obviously a tutorial we put this
little platform here so that at least
the players can get for a little bit of
protection gosh but that is just really
simple really simple but fun mechanic
here so the key is to leave your body in
a safe position while you're kind of in
that mold that goes for that's right
exactly you got to make sure that it's
in a safe position or you're just
constantly protecting it yeah there's
some enemies are weak as sometimes like
you saw that play monster we touch his
back button that play monster he he can
attack you from this side but and if
you're in front of him also you're gonna
attack you however you can also just go
for the side and that's a surprise right
so so each enemy has their own little
weak points like that
now you notice this little block over
here right it's not here but you go back
to 2d now because this 2d
though these are very now tell us about
the developer far along and development
and just about the whole thing with the
game as far as the engine what are you
guys using we use another widget for
okay we started development in June so
it's we ran eight months total
developing right now and I love that you
also have an aspect India for the
speedrunning community that was they get
acclimated they can actually try to
start doing and be each other's time now
are we going online leaderboards with
this kind of oh all this currently it's
currently online right now nice now
platforms what are we looking at before
we go go struck so right now we're doing
for PC Windows and Linux we're doing
Xbox one and PlayStation 4 nice and it
looks like we might actually be able to
do a Nintendo switch switch game
basically we're doing all meet your
platform nice so what I know I said
mouthful notice above okay we still got
boss actually though let's go flower
boss I'm not the greatest name so here
this is where we put all the skills that
player has learned in Torelli to test
down so you search in between 2d and 3d
so you can see here that's because
they're over there on the left side so
you switch then you wait and then if you
remember boom so but you can't attack
them unless you're in 3d mode people
you're gonna want to sign I got here
some very intense blows mechanics yeah
you got to be careful because that vine
well still damage your physical poor I
remember you got to take care of that
more just gotta wait for that bye this
is deep man
it is and then so there he goes that so
that's the first days so every boss
fight will have three different stages
so it should Terri's do so this one will
do a lot this is where all that dual
jumping mechanics come into play and
then you just whack whack whack whack
whack whack whack whack whack oh he hit
me so yeah all these suckers go down
[Music]
this is intention I don't think I'm beat
this boss like this right here to switch
it with the tool I'm watching people
play like this is intense right here
so this that's your foul stench is
really so where's your body their bodies
only to the left I'm worried about his
body but his body
Wow forty level so every every every
environment has five levels and we're
gonna have eight environments so that's
40 levels each and again every every
level will have their own leaderboard so
the completion is that you know all
those speedrunners everything and
there's give you a lot of hidden stuff
too so all for the hundred percent
commission there's all the ones I want
to take there's tweet time I just play
the game or we and then give me mirror
we have some action - so froze at like
tribe I really want to like have some
combat we have some combat stuff for
that comment
okay listen man very impressive way more
deeper than that thought they go goes -
there's a lot of complexities here very
high about this title now my question is
again just for reinforces we come in PC
first so it just depends on if we can
get an attendance which confirmed then
we might try to do a world water release
simultaneous so PC and all consoles if
not will do PC first and do a staggered
release for the council's needle goes
jump man you got to support it because
out here moving man the I'm lover when
I'm saying we're looking forward to
chart this progress of this game and
absolute pleasure brother hey thank you
very much we're to here first
I don't know podcast loads gave me that
day
[Music]